it felt like the 49ers were going to
easily beat the seahawks who could
muster nothing offensively early on
but between that play the emmanuel
sanders injury that changes everything
and it swung to the seahawks and then it
swung back and it swung back and it's
chris sims and it's peter king and it's
mike florio for a full hour talking
about the monday night football game
peter chris and i have been talking
about it for the last hour we'll go
ahead and give you first word your
reaction to what was one of the best
monday night games that i can remember
ever seeing last night
i mean it's one of the best monday night
games in history it's the game of the
year in the nfl
uh and they're very few times that a
much hyped game lives up to the hype and
last night was one of them i'm struck
overarchingly by three things
number one the seattle new players
played such huge roles in this game even
if you consider josh gordon just caught
two passes yeah but both of them were
for first downs
in important parts of the game very late
in the game
quandary digs was a huge uh defensive
play uh jadavian clowney with maybe
maybe overall the best game of his
career and that's saying something for a
former first pick in the draft and
obviously one of the other things that
you think of when you look at this game
is the inability of jimmy garoppolo to
lift his game to any level near
what was needed to win this game at one
point
i remember looking up at the tv and i
said i i cannot remember jimmy garoppolo
playing with happy feet like this look
this is whatever like his 18th nfl start
so we don't really know him yet but that
was a bad night for jimmy garoppolo and
for 49er fans who want to love him who
want to have faith in them and i'll say
finally
i have never seen an assistant coach
shown so much
on a television broadcast
ever
then robert it's every week and it's
become a new thing ever yeah it was that
i mean that was incredibly excessive i
think
and my whole thought was
after the seattle seahawks
on nine consecutive possessions hold the
49ers scoreless
i'm saying on my tv give us ken norton
give us equal time for ken norton a good
point absurd good point peter was very
real robert sala
yeah that hey it was like robert saleh
invented defensive football and i just
i've had enough i've just had enough of
it it's ridiculous and look their
defense played well
that was not a devastating defensive
performance like we thought
that the 49er defense
might actually put up there
but but i mean those are my sort of
original three thoughts
well
i guess i'll go all right i mean so yeah
i there's so many things to talk first
off you're right about the robert salah
thing he deserves a lot of credit he's
been phenomenal all year long there's no
doubt about that but yes it was
excessive and you're right just from the
uh the prospects of being fair like you
would think they'd show ken norton jr
just a few more times because his
defense really was the story of the game
with the turnovers what they did uh you
know you're right the the 49ers defense
uh the 49ers defense i think is good was
more dominant than we'll remember in
this game
just because overtime is going to mess
up our brain a little bit a lot of yards
by that seahawks offense in overtime and
let's not forget i mean the seahawks
never really drove the ball all night
long either the defense set them up for
some short fields but to your point
peter you're exactly right there and
there's i mean you you hit it the the
new players on the seahawks and whether
it's rookies dk metcalf and what he did
but mike we haven't even talked about
that play yet i mean that's how many
good players there are in the game they
get the strip sack fumble they get the
ball back we're going holy cow the
seahawks are going to go in at halftime
up 14 to 10
and jakwa jakwisky tarte strips the ball
out of dk's metcalf's hands as he's
going into the end zone i mean there's
just so many plays in general but to the
big point and back to what peter said
you're right peter you know jimmy
garoppolo i'm not going to look at it
and go oh i'm going to hit the panic
button but he certainly didn't answer
the question of oh gosh if the 49ers
can't run the ball and shanahan can't
design all these creative plays and if
they have an injury like no george
kittle or emmanuel sanders uh i i still
think the question remains can jimmy
garoppolo carry them in those moments
against the better defenses in football
you know i'll say here in the the
interception was not his fault but uh
but in general yes he got away with a
few other interceptions that should have
been and it wasn't his best game that's
for sure
that was the nagging question about the
49ers going into the season garoppolo
coming off of the torn acl suffered week
3 in 2018 against the chiefs will he be
healthy will he be effective and if he
doesn't get it done the way they
structure the contracts in san francisco
it's very easy to escape before april 1.
you have trades free agency you can do a
lot of work in advance of the draft you
know where you're going to be picking
you can make a lot of decisions before
you have to make a decision about
picking up more fully guaranteed money
for your starting quarterback and once
the 49ers start winning games we forget
about this cloud that's hovering over
jimmy garoppolo well they're not winning
these games early in the year because
garoppolo is coming out and playing like
joe montana and making big throws in big
spots to win these games and at some
point garoppolo's got to do it peter and
we saw some of it thursday night week
nine against the cardinals but last
night was when it fell to garoppolo to
make it happen without george kittle
make it happen without emmanuel sanders
and that offense changed
dramatically once sanders exited with a
rib injury and wouldn't it be something
if the 49ers end up having a deep
playoff run a great team on both sides
of the ball and they get to march and
they say we can do better at quarterback
we're done with jimmy g
i doubt they're gonna do that mike but
three quick observations on what what
you just said and following chris number
one
the biggest difference it may have been
a game that was decided by the narrowest
of margins as the clock ran out and i
get that
there was a huge difference in this game
between russell wilson and jimmy
garoppolo sure at the most important
position in football
the seattle seahawks have a huge
advantage at quarterback that's number
one number two
one of the reasons honestly mike that
that this game came down to the end
is that the easiest interception of kj
wright's career and i have no idea how
he didn't catch the ball it was almost
like jimmy garoppolo was saying here kj
i'm giving you the gift of a lifetime
and for some reason he he muffed it
so that actually gave the 49ers life
yeah
you know when overtime bobby wagner
dropped it yeah i mean yeah bobby
but at least dropping on off side at
least the bobby wagner interception was
a tough catch yeah right you know the kj
right catch was like you're out in the
backyard lobbing the ball to each other
yeah i mean that was unbelievable that
he didn't catch that
i think the last thing i would say just
about the whole quarterback situation is
that
russell wilson played
a long time in this game without tyler
lockett
and and just think of russell wilson
and what he has done this season jacob
hollister was not even on their team two
months ago
and last night he was a gigantic
part of this team or three months ago
whatever it was he was a gigantic part
of the game plan by necessity and it's
like russell wilson just doesn't care
russell wilson doesn't care who is out
there he's gonna figure it out that guy
whoever it was atkins and over to i
never heard of this guy
and here he is catching big passes josh
gordon hey look i know there's a lot of
great players in the nfl right now but
russell wilson is the singular
uh most dominant player i think in
football and that says a lot when we've
seen lamar jackson recently when we see
deshaun watson christian mccaffrey
give me russell
peter we talked about this last hour i
mean for all these quarterbacks that are
making 30 million or more russell
wilson's the only one maybe aaron
rodgers to a lesser extent but russell's
got no help and last night especially in
overtime you said tyler locker where's
tyler lockett and the guy potentially
has compartment syndrome who knows how
long he'll be out and and it's this
revolving door of running backs
receivers and tight ends russell wilson
is the guy that they deliberately made
the center of the universe when they
began to move on from veteran players
after the 2017 season they paid russell
wilson huge money and dollar for dollar
as the quarterbacks making more than 20
million a year go he's the best value
chris yeah yes he is i mean he's uh to
peter's point you know he's he's been
the best player in football to to this
point of the season the most dominant
the guy that can make the most with le
the least uh you know it just there's
nothing you can do to stop him at times
really and yeah he fumbled and threw an
interception last night but again we
weren't looking at the seattle seahawks
like their greatest show on turf we
think their offense is really good why
because they're somewhat consistent with
the run game and they do that but we
think they're great on offense because
of russell wilson it just it really
stops there i don't think anyone's going
oh man brian schottenheimer who did a
really good job and does a really good
job but nobody's like knocking down the
door like oh man we need to get him
because he's the new innovative
offensive coach in football no they are
afforded a lot of luxuries because of
russell wilson's talent he's the
clutches quarterback in the game he's
the most determined unflappable
quarterback uh he's up there with all
the some of the all-time greats as far
as brady any of those as far as clutch
and just never
blinking an eye and big moments it just
doesn't matter you always feel like he's
going to deliver and you know i was
texting with rodney harrison there in
overtime and we were just like man
russell wilson gets the ball third time
in a row like there's just no way
they're gonna stop them for the third
time in a row in overtime you just knew
it once they got the ball back you were
like he's gonna make another play to get
them down there to kick another chance
to win this game and kick the field goal
then of course he delivered because he
almost always does deliver he's just
truly a special special player
yeah absolutely
go ahead okay
just one very quick thing malik turner
jacob hollister josh gordon yeah
can you please give john schneider
executive of the year in november can we
close out the balloting right now i mean
this is this is an organization that
understands how to build correctly
and build sometimes for the long term
but the seattle seahawks right now last
night showed how you can have a premier
team
with a lot of bit players playing huge
roles right yeah traded for clowning
quandary digs all those things are are
reflections of john schneider and what
he's done there as a gm though you're
right
but ultimately getting russell wilson
for 35 million a year before it became
an awkward situation remember he set the
deadline in april he was serious about
it they got it done or it really could
have gotten very expensive because after
a game last night 40 million a year 45
million a year may be the right number
for russell wilson
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports